hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and Terry Erickson here love comma Tara
Erickson yeah love come on Simon a roll
of three that's they get it yeah that is
a roll be pass that himself comma
coca-cola get out of here I'll take care
of it
love comma Simon I brought it all around
so make sure to edit the video yeah so
there's this movie called love Simon out
that stars Nick Robinson who you might
know from Jurassic world and everything
everything this is true that a lot of
people are asking me to check out and
he's your type he's young ninety-five
he's 22 23 and March you can Terry get
all the young guys you can get 15 year
olds if you want a video just got b2 is
I've got it you got it you get 22 you
look at least like 30 pages a day
Shaffer Niraj Trish Nam will do it after
the video sorry
aces the most part my life is totally
normal
how your family but actually like and
there's my friends we do everything
friends do we drink way too much nice
talk we walk working on cars so I'm just
like you except I have one huge a secret
[Music]
big secret
[Music]
[Music]
why you're blue I'm just like you
this was mistake it's nice to know
there's another guy at school with the
same secret when did you first realize
it was a bunch of little things my first
girlfriend
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
and where who knows it's supposed to be
my thing this plane this is about to
not the guy exact he looks like Ansel
Elgort he does it looks like it looks
like Caucasian male actor in Los Angeles
your type he's done keeping his story
straight
that's an interesting movie it's a
really a love story you know yes because
he's falling in love with this online
persona of someone who says a gate - but
I think it's a trick in the editing I
think he finds out who it is rather
within the first like thirty minutes of
the movie we find out who the other guy
is and it's not a scene no I think like
maybe like 50 to 60 minutes in I feel
like everybody's secret yeah I feel like
him in the am and the secret guy within
30 40 minutes we know who the guy is
they're secretly talking still just an
email maybe they haven't met up yet they
like avoid each other at school cuz
they're like all and we both know but
like nobody else can know
do they just keep emailing know that who
the other guy is and then they're gonna
talk secretly for a long time then it's
all gonna blow up I'd be like a twist
where obviously there'll be a twist
where it's like we will have known the
guy for a while but we won't know for
sure it's the guy he's emailing then LBL
reveal that oh it's been this guy the
whole time the guy who's blowing leaves
outside whose boots he likes no no no
we'll keep people and there's a book we
like yeah we all know that that's gonna
happen Jennifer Garner I like her I like
her too she's great and he's like hurt
felt like be traumas straight up mom
yeah and John it's cool seeing josh
duhamel doing a role like this too
playing a dad i like yeah right on him
not with like a gun or something yeah
that's cool soon for a regular guy and
this looks like a great starring role
for this dude I mean he was in this
movie called everything everything Nick
Robinson who was the sexy male love
interest of the edgy mystery and this
was like a role better suited for him it
feels like a lived-in role it feels like
a role that could be very identifiable
for a lot of people in terms of the
romantic aspect it's kind of like a game
high school version of you've got me a
little boy got male was amazing I think
it's gonna be a really strong movie for
the LGBTQ community sometimes I think
I'm destined to care so much about one
person it nearly kills me oh yeah every
once in a while when I watch a love
story with high school or sometimes I'm
sitting there going what a bunch of
idiots you're in high school you're
gonna get over each other one day and
then other times when I hear lines like
that
yeah it hits me that oh boy I know that
feeling me I know yeah I know that
feeling really well and it starts when
we're teenagers yeah this is a film that
I think adults can also latch on to as
well well duh I mean I always think I'm
costly destined to like just think about
one person and it nearly kills me John
yeah you get a Humphries is his last
name right yeah Humphries marries No got
it well I think about Humphries there's
a lot of different Humphries I know I
feel like it would be heartbreaking too
because obviously there's gonna be a
girl who's into him and there's gonna be
whoever the male counterpart that he's
into as well oh I totally fell for a guy
at my school cuz I went to musical
theater school grad for college
he was like I'm gay and we dated for
like six months and I was like I was sad
it legit did happen well we were really
good friends and then I we dated for
maybe not six months me it was like a
couple months three months and it was in
the beginning the first year that
started school so it was in the new Leon
you know you mean you just like bull and
most
but then I didn't know I thought it was
not gay sorry are you trying to be gay
it will sag as I really liked him hey
okay I mean it happens it's like cool
great yeah I've heard that happened way
more with girls than guys do girl who's
like bye see you later
I heard mostly that it happens to guys
as they get older with women as they age
they're just like I'm over guys now and
they want to like date women that I have
heard when you get older Wow thirties
forties I've heard that a lot where a
lesbians are like I was married with
kids and then I left and now I'm with my
wife have you ever had feelings for
someone that you haven't actually met
but only message online I once did
really yeah many years ago met a girl
through Craigslist and why she started
talking to me I had no idea what she
looked like I started liking her and
then eventually we just talked on the
phone then one day we met up and she
just happened to be
[Music]
that was a good that was a good loop
there Gregory everybody got it everybody
knew where you were going everyone's
like wow that's the question all the
time
he made a loop he looped it back around
right well there's a guy I'm definitely
in love with it's Niraj Krishnan over at
patreon Niraj is one of our Indian
subscribers
he lives in New Jersey hardcore Indian
like that
and he always gives us these indie drama
requests to check out so I thought loves
Simon his fitting and tone with the kind
of movies you like love Simon he's from
New Jersey he's saying you gotta watch
he didn't you don't just move to New
Jersey and get in New Jersey acts good
morning you want a cup of coffee you
don't want coffee why do you want coffee
when I'm gonna get expressed on their
watch the real rejects I'm gonna watch
the real rejects I want him to watch
love Simon 24 hours part of that was
probably what you were doing what'd he
think this is her interpretation on
right yeah it is you do Jersey no
they're more like a poor aren't they
you're kind of doing New York I'll do it
what are you doing Oh get some coffee
it's rush hour watch it real reject when
watch love Simon that's a great Niraj
crush not impression I'm glad you're
here for this patron I'm telling him
what you're actually like is he he
didn't have yet to explore that this is
why I pay Tara $45 a video to be rich I
love you and I love Simon and I kind of
liked Hera I liked Niraj you live in New
Jersey kid and you asked it to watch
this I'm gonna go see this movie you
like taking another improv
[Laughter]
don't worry this is just how I them when
I film I I bring light into it is not
subscribe and check out our patreon
while your wrap